position d'épargnants sinon pas annonce
son poids dans la charger tout gagné
bienvenue sur le tournage de müller
lunaire sera l'histoire de deux frères
qui sont très différents vins très
créatif et le tro créatif mamet et
l'autre pas du tout plus réaliste et
terre à terre battue face à ces unités
fixes et rêvait d un corps de papillon
vivre une aventure qui va combler les
différences non non non non tu veux que
ce fameux voyous qui arrive dans une
soirée qui veut juste un peu de silence
un peu de calme il est poursuivi par les
flics et c'est sa part un petit peu en
vrille et il devient très menaçant en
sortant une arme beaucoup de tension
beaucoup de danger continue optionnel
pas pour appeler les flics n'ont inventé
cette petite situation pour que en fait
les deux personnages les deux frères
sont obligés de collaborer
il impose une sorte de mise en scène à
ses autres otages qui sont contraints de
fermer qui donne l'heure lors le maximum
pour faire
je me suis inspiré de ma relation avec
mon grand frère on n'avait pas à tomber
d'accord sur ce qu'on aimait dans la vie
et puis aujourd'hui la vie nous a un peu
plus rapproché on est beaucoup plus
proche aujourd'hui que 40
quand j'ai commencé à écrire l'histoire
j'ai demandé en tout cas l'avis sur le
sur le script a refait les cra qui a
tout de suite réagi la dia ça ça ça me
parle
les enjeux étaient assez fort et le
bluff été assez web payants et de faire
peur à quelqu'un qui nous fait peur moi
ça me parler pas mal on arrive à faire
croire aux voyous qu'il faut partir
parce qu'on est très dense ce qui est
faux regardez ce mortal c'est une fois
qu'on a un petit peu retravaillé
ensemble sur le scénario je lui ai dit
bon bain est ce que tu veut le réaliser
et je suis vraiment content d'avoir fait
avec mx que gilles hull
il a sa méthode il a une exigence aussi
vis-à-vis des comédiens et la mise en
scène sur le contre chance de partir un
tout petit plus comme une flèche au
début des crises et donc je peux partir
comme une flèche au début mix d'actifs m
dans une première version n'était plus
sûr qu'à me faisait croire aux voyous
que il était de mafia très russe et j'ai
pu un peu m'amuser a rajouté par exemple
le personnage de riec sorte de mama qui
gère des centres d'orphelins sa sainte
ça paraissait un peu évident que
j'incarne le petit frère est en fait en
cherchant des comédiens vraiment sur la
fin les dernières semaines on s'est dit
ah non mais on change le change en
inverse les rôles
une démarche de comedia c'est assez
intéressante et puis il gaspard est
vraiment parfait pour faire le mec dans
la lune et camille arrêtent d'aider
casting pour trouver des gens ne
regardent et plein plein plein plein de
comédiens et elle est un petit peu plus
loin peut-être qu'on voit moins souvent
sur internet ou même pas du tout là on a
plus écrit en pensant vraiment aux
personnages et aux mélodies
je ne peux pas vous dire que je la
science et que jojo sonia moi je joue le
rôle de homme grand plus communément
appelé le geek qui fait chier c'est pas
du tout pour une éducation c'est plus
pour vous donner un petit coup de main
et je viens pointé du doigt les
incohérences évidentes commandes et
mettra peut-être voyager avec sa relique
bien dans le monde ils ne sont plus en
racks depuis au moins quatre pages le
tournage s'est très bien passé il ya
beaucoup beaucoup lieu par contre
c'était quand même compliqué de tout
tourner un peu en même temps très peu de
jours pendant qu'on tournait par exemple
la librairie le matin l'équipe commence
à monter les lumières à l'appartement
dans tout était fait un peu en même
temps en parallèle on avait dû tourner
des séquences aussi en extérieur où il
ya le personnage du voyou qui se
baladent et qui va supprimer dans tout
ça a été tourné un peu improvisée dans
la rue puis dans la partie et pas
beaucoup des stars pour avoir
l'autorisation de le prendre en photo
je ne regarde que lui tu tombes sur le
pays que tu le lâche plus le regard
qu'on me tende gaspard silence pour la
fille du s'il vous plaît moteur on a
essayé d'apporter un souci du détail
l'annoncé séquence là tout le monde se
débrouiller le livre il dédicace à la
fin c'est un vrai faux livres café
camille dabrowski qui n'existe pas ni le
livre nick a mis en vente dans aucune
librairie le deuxième run va trouver
aussi des fautes d'orthographe le 2e
romain de camions le de romance parce
qu'il est papa
voulu faire un court métrage qui se
rapproche le plus possible du cinéma
chef-opérateur nous a fait une image et
une lumière si julien a passé un petit
peu de temps dessus
j'avais très envie d'essayer un peu
autre chose que ce que je fais
d'habitude avec des machineries qu'on
n'a pas trop utilisés jusqu'ici nous sur
le web d'aller voir dans des plans un
peu plus aéré ou mois au montage
j'aurais pas le choix de le mettre telle
qu'elle tue le rendez vous sur paris
mais bon j'ai fait mon temps maman m'a
dit que je pouvais bien chez toi
moi la musique c'est une partie qui est
super importante sont composés c'est pas
des musiques qu'on trouve sur internet
on a fait travailler edouard joguet
c'est un artiste que j'adore et on a
aussi en générique de fin est un artiste
que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle pomme
pour terminer en chansons quoi comme à
bollywood c'est la réf
je suis je suis super content de pouvoir
projeter en fait le court métrage sur un
grand écran
du coup dans un cinéma max linder
internet c'est bien parce que je peux
partager des vidéos avec absolument tout
le monde et tout mais dans une salle à
voir les réactions en direct ça c'est
assez unique
j'espère et je pense que ça parlera
beaucoup de gens m'ont tous créatif pour
dessiner avec des crayons comme ça
étonnante
moi je continue à raconter des histoires
pour la suite mais
[Musique]
un même toit est coupée